in this part
of the democratic republic of the congo
medical care arrives by water
the rivers are the country's roads the
ambulance boat is part of a conservation
project
and was funded by the worldwide fund for
nature to help people
in the hungary nature reserve didier
mazongo is the project's director
we are now in the nature reserve in the
ingary triangle where there
are quite a number of villages the aim
of this project
is to improve the living conditions of
the population
while helping them preserve its
biodiversity
and that's sorely needed the rainforest
in central africa
actually has one of the world's highest
levels of biodiversity
but the forests rivers and sandbanks
here are empty
civil war poverty and hardship have
almost wiped out the fauna
people hunt anything that's edible
didier mazongo says that while the
nature reserve is covered in water
almost all year long
there are still animals here but they're
very shy
we're now in the heart of the reserve
with its specific character as a swamp
forest
which plays a crucial role in
maintaining the water supply
and preserving biodiversity you can
still find rare antelope species
and even hippopotami in this river
the people along the rivers live mainly
from fishing
most use mosquito nets for their catch
hardly any have broad mesh nets as a
result
the fish stocks are severely depleted
many species are threatened with
extinction
didier mazongo and his colleague albert
bakonza assessed the situation at a
village market
how big do these fish normally get
as long as the poverty here remains so
great it will be hard to keep the fauna
along the congo from disappearing
so the ungiri triangle project is a sort
of noah's ark
from which one day animals might
repopulate the nearly empty forests and
rivers
at least that's what didier mazongo and
his fellow campaigners hope